[Music]
[Applause]
get some more phone calls coming up
albert breer senior nfl reporter lead
content strategist monday morning
quarterback albert's on vacation fritzy
still tracked him down and uh albert
kind enough to join us on the program
albert thank you for uh allowing us to
interrupt your uh your vacation there
no it's okay like we had uh we actually
were gonna be set up at the house that
we rented and my kid has to go to the
aquarium and this is the time of year i
can't really say no so i'm outside the
aquarium trying to find in uh
an internet connection which so probably
everybody in like a you know a 500 yard
radius is like what the hell is that guy
doing walking around with a laptop
well thanks for joining us we won't keep
you alone what do you expect to happen
tomorrow during the uh
uh hearing for deshaun watson
yeah you know i i think people have sort
of mistaken it to be that um you know
sue l robinson the former u.s district
court judge is just going to hear
deshawn's case he's also she's also
going to hear the case from the league
and she's going to hear the case from
the union and
everybody knows that the sides have an
idea of what everybody's gonna be
presenting and um you know i i think the
league has been um strident and wanting
a year suspension my understanding is
that the settlement talks collapsed over
the league's insistence on a year
suspension
and now they're going to be looking for
something indefinite where he'd have to
apply to get back in after a year
and then the union is going to ask for
much lighter punishment on the basis of
the league's case not being as strong as
a lot of people think it is and the key
component to the union's case is the
league tomorrow is only going to be
bringing the cases of five women so
we've heard about the 24 women who've
sued and obviously other women
who've alleged wrongdoing on on on on
the part of of watson
um but the league is only going to be
bringing the cases of five women
tomorrow
um and you know and then of course the
union's case is that based on that and
based on what we've seen with owners
like
jerry jones robert craftsman especially
dan snyder
a year suspension is way too much um and
then you know after that i think as you
know
she'll take that under advisement make a
recommendation on penalty and then it'll
either go to the commissioner or his
designee
the nfl is there a max that they could
ask for
can you hear me albert
i got you yeah um is what would be the
max you think the nfl could ask for
well the nfl is going to ask for an
indefinite suspension which
um i determine the cba is actually
called banishment which we've seen
players get that in the past and and
essentially what that means is the
player's gone for the period for
a period of a year and it's almost like
he's not in the league right like so his
contract tolls he's not paid
um and then you know after he's served a
season then he has the opportunity to
apply for reinstatement and in a lot of
cases it does wind up being a year
suspension but that's what the nfl is
going to be looking at whereas you know
obviously the union is going to look at
it and say
that
again based on the cases you know of
craft of jones of of schneider
and the way the league handled those um
you know a banishment penalty would be
way too much and again like my my
understanding is the settlement talks
centered on the idea of a year
suspension
and watson wasn't going to go for that
the league you know basically offered
that as less than banishment they just
serve a year suspension and you're back
in
um and the league wouldn't move off of
it
of its position there
um watson's team obviously wouldn't go
for the year suspension so the
settlement talks collapsed and we have
our hearing tomorrow
uh
who gets traded first baker mayfield or
jimmy g
[Music]
you know this gets interesting now um
just because there are some moving parts
with both guys obviously with baker you
know the desean situation as much as
and look like baker
has made it clear to everybody around
him he's done with the browns and um
this is unfixable and even if the browns
doubled back to him and
like
after say watson is suspended for a year
he wouldn't want to go back there it may
still present the best opportunity and i
don't know the browns would reverse
course on this because they certainly
haven't operated over the last three
months like a team that was leaving the
door open at all
um but if it is a year i mean would they
leave that door open maybe or reopen
that door i mean maybe um whereas with
jimmy g
i just think once his shoulder heals the
dynamic changes a little bit
and then as has been the case with
mayfield the money comes into play
and jimmy's in a little bit of a
different spot than baker is baker has
that 18.8 million dollars fully
guaranteed so all he has to do is sit
there and he he'll get it you know
whereas with jimmy
that money doesn't become guaranteed
until week one so you know if another
team wants to come in and negotiate with
him and say we're willing to trade for
you but we're only willing to pay x
like jimmy might feel compelled to take
it because if the niners cut him well
then you know obviously there's a lot of
uncertainty on how much money he's going
to make in 2022. so
i would say the likelihood is
and likely it has been the baker would
get moved first
but just
the situation with deshawn's um you know
case um you know going through this week
and then
uh you know i think the the health of
jimmy's shoulder and jimmy being able to
throw within the next couple of weeks
could change the dynamic talking albert
breer senior nfl reporter lead content
strategist for the monday morning
quarterback
feels like every year this time daniel
snyder is somehow stepping in it and
somehow he steps out of it but um
is this different this year
there are two things that i i think
roger goodell has done over the last six
months that make this a little bit
different dan
and i think you and i both know roger's
very very careful and calculated on
everything he says about any owner
um and you know i you know back at the
super bowl and i think we've talked
about this before roger actually
detailed for everyone at a press
conference
the process for ousting an owner
i i may have been the only one i was
stunned when he did that because that to
me signals
somebody signed off on him saying that
somebody was okay with him saying that
so that's number one and then last week
he continuously in front of congress
positioned daniel snyder being out of
day-to-day operations for the commanders
as a suspension snyder's team quietly
has pushed back very hard against that
notion so i think you add one thing to
the other right you add roger's
willingness to talk about how to house
an owner to
roger positioning snyder's absence from
the team as a suspension um and as a
punishment for everything that went on
in that building in the last 20 years
and i think you're starting to see where
i don't know if the owners are going to
have the stomach to vote one of their
own out because i don't think any of
them want to set that precedent they
don't want anybody looking through their
trash too
you know and so i i don't know they have
the appetite for that but what i do
think could happen over the coming
months and i think you may be starting
to see signs of this with the way
roger's operating
is the temperature might get turned up
on snyder where they try to test him and
stuff keeps coming out on him and maybe
they try to see
if there's a way to force him out
without having to vote him out where it
gets to the point where it's untenable
for him to own the team anymore and he
decides i can get four or five billion
for this team i don't need this trouble
anymore i'm out he's obviously already
shown that the threshold for that's
going to be really really high
he didn't walk away the way that jerry
richardson walked away a few years ago
when his own scandal happened in
carolina
but i wouldn't be surprised if the
owners in the league
try to turn up the pressure on daniel
snyder to sell
um before taking any sort of action on
voting on him on on his viability as an
owner
warren sapp made some headlines
suggesting that colin kaepernick's
workout with the raiders was a
disaster if you heard anything to the
contrary
i you know when i i like
coming out of the the workout
really what i heard was he's in shape
and he looked fine uh but like i i don't
think i didn't hear it was a disaster at
the same time i didn't hear it was any
sort of revelation you know
i i like the the sense i got from the
raiders people is it's about where we
expected it to be
um based on you know what you've seen um
over the last few years the clips of him
throwing and everything else still has a
really strong arm again he's in shape
um you know they were able to test him
in certain ways do you look great i mean
maybe not but i think you know he
certainly looked like he could play
quarterback in the nfl
given you know enough ramp up time to do
it
um so like that was sort of what i can't
heard coming out about i didn't hear a
warren sapp heard but i also didn't hear
that this was some sort of like light
turning on for the raiders where it's
like wow how is this guy out of the
league the last few years
uh go back to the aquarium
thanks for joining me sorry about the
connection issues dan we'll do better
next time i promise
next time uh next time i'll be on on a
more solid connection here thank you
albert that's uh everybody can stop and
everybody can stop looking at me weird
around here now
albert breer it looks like he's talking
to nobody on his phone somewhere
on his vacation senior nfl reporter lee
content strategist at the uh monday
morning quarterback fritzy goes um hey
albert's on his vacation i said oh
telling that we don't want to bother him
he goes no he wants to know what time
that he can join us
and we appreciate him i think he's one
of the
bright reporters covering the game